hello everyone and welcome to one of the
most amazing chess puzzles I've ever
seen the first time I saw this puzzle
was some 10 years ago and I really
enjoyed it I was really blown away by it
and then I haven't seen it for quite
some time and since I started my channel
I decided that I will show it at some
point but I never got around to it
always doing this video or that video
and not really not really doing all that
much puzzles but it is it is definitely
a puzzle you do want to show to everyone
so the backstory of the of how the
puzzle came to be and about this
tournament in 1987 in Brussels this
super tournament is a very thoroughly
explained in an article that I will link
in the description below the first thing
you will see it's an article on chess
based calm I found by a Friedrich
Friedel as he was he was present there
in the 1987 brussels super tournament so
as the story goes it at first they
didn't know who created the puzzle a lot
of people said that it was created there
it was created then this person created
this person created but it was actually
created in 1970 but around 1970 by the
dutch end game composer there you have
it the gentleman on the left
casement brooklyn and it was only
published in 1997
so some almost 30 years after after it
was created but as he showed it to some
friends and the puzzle was really
incredible it got out a lot of people
saw it a lot of us from grandmasters saw
it and so so it happened in this super
tournament of 1987 where English
grandmaster james Plaskett
along with friedrich Friedel was
enjoying this puzzle he showed it to him
and as the grandmasters were playing in
their super tournament when they
finished their game they would join them
and take a crack at the puzzle so here
is a just to show you some of the
players from this super tournament there
you have it there is a Gary Kasparov
analyzing his game with Anatoly Karpov
there's me he'll hide in the back
smoking a cigarette so only some of the
players from the super tournament the
three world champions and here are some
of the other players these are the
standings the final standings of this
super tournament
so it was one a shared first place bike
as part of a new boomer Lubavitch
followed by carp of course teaming and
tile in sixth place which is very
impressive as tile was really preparing
for this tournament he came there as a
journalist and then as a Robert here hip
now a fell ill after round one then fell
took his place and decided to play the
entire tournament and finishing sixth
not definitely not bad especially for
1987 towel so there you have it
and it's really one of those puzzles I
will show the solution in this video but
if you don't want to check it out I'll
totally understand it it's a great
puzzle to enjoy for for weeks or months
you know and until you until you crack
it but if you want to just enjoy the
puzzle and then share it with your
friends and family that's also fine so
as a weakened in your story two of them
were enjoying the puzzle grandmasters
after they finished their game took a
crack at the puzzle no one was able to
solve it then Amy health tile came and
he also took a crack at the puzzle he
tried to solve it for some ten minutes
but he couldn't do it then he got well
then he left the press room and then he
went for a walk and they said that after
he came back he had a Eureka moment he
figured out the puzzle and then he
presented it to them and there it is
it's a white to play in the wind and
it's it's not an easy task since black
is a up material a whole lot and the
white doesn't really have much going for
him and I you're even welcome to use an
engine to solve the puzzle because the
engine doesn't solve it here just to
show you this is a this is a chess or
what ah
okay I missed it whoa yeah okay just
give me a second I need I need to load
it I think I was using a different
profile so it's missing at the moment
but there it is okay there we have it so
this is an evaluation from chess calm
with an engine there you have it it says
at depth 53 I left it overnight so it
would go up to the depth 53 it says that
black is still winning that white cannot
win this and here is a here
an evaluation from from elite chess
engine also at depth 54 also it has
cloud analysis still says black is
winning so the engine is not really not
really going to help you on this one
unless you have like an engine with
cloud analysis where someone already and
to enter the solution then it will the
solution will pop up but you are welcome
to use an engine to help you solve it if
you if you want so here I will now
present the puzzle for those of you who
don't want to see the solution I just
closed the video and then come back to
it after you've decided you wanted to
see it but once again it's white to play
in the wind however however you can so
for those of you who are still here I
will now present the solution and for
those of you who were trying to solve it
for a month or two and then came back
after we sold it congratulations to you
guys you guys are incredible so as a
star came back from his walk he
presented the following idea so the
point is yes white does have something
going for him he can bring a queen into
the game the problem is if you bring a
queen into the game just night f7 check
black wins the Queen kinky seven I've
characters here King characters and
there's nothing to be done here so what
you would have to do here instead of
bringing your queen into the game is
actually Knight to f6 check and now
there are several ideas possible if you
go to h8 then of course the Queen comes
into the game with check which is
excellent for white another thing if you
go something like King to g6 then you
allow Bishop to h5 check and now again
if you go to g7 sorry if you go to g7
then just the queen and the knight of
seven no longer works because the bishop
covers the f7 square and after Bishop h5
check if you capture the knight again
just b8 Queen and the knight the bishop
still covers the f7 square so what
happens is that after Knight f6 check
only good move is King g7 but now white
continues with Knight to h5 check again
what is black do if King to f7
then you just bring the Queen into the
game because now the King occupies the
f7 square so black cannot use it to fork
the king and the Queen if you go pink
h7 then it's a blush of the sea to check
again forcing the kings to go up the
board and then d8 comes again with trick
so after night h5 only good movies King
to g6 so how does a wife continue here
bishop the c2 with check again nothing
much to do here if you go back then just
d8 queen the the night no longer has
access to the f7 square so King captures
on h5 and now in cress incredible as it
seems now comes to remove d8 Queen and
now what happens here black of course
has to go for the Queen if you don't if
you don't capture the Queen then White
has a queen and is just winning he it
will take some time but he will surely
win this game so black has to go for the
Queen Knight to f7 check King the e6 we
have Knight captures Queen on the 8 with
check King to f5 and all of a sudden the
White King has completely blocked off
any escape routes for the black king and
the pawn and g3 prevents the King from
escaping via the h4 square so now if
Bishop the d1 check happens its mate
after e to visual characters who will be
checkmate so black has to prevent this
black plays e 2 and threatens to bring
the Queen into the game but white says
no problem
Bishop the e4 says ok you bring your
Queen into the game and I deliver
checkmate
so of course black cannot bring the
Queen enter game black has to bring a
knight into the game to cover the f3
square so now Bishop to f3 is impossible
but this is only the beginning of our
bishops journey
Bishop goes to d5 now with the threat of
Bishop c4 followed by Bishop to e2
checkmate
so again black has to defend against
death the only way black and
successfully defend is by playing c2
white again goes for Bishop c4 threatens
Bishop the d2 checkmate
well after Knight f3 blocks you will
catch run after we would make and now
again if Queen choose Bishop e2 so once
again black has to bring a knight into
the game so black already has four
knights on the board but now now D 2
square is covered of course you don't
have better to eat you but now comes the
Bishop to b5 it's threatening Bishop -
eh checkmate
so again what do you do here Knight the
c7 attack the bishop and also
keep an eye on the e8 square not
allowing better up to eight we have the
only move left for white the seek
checkmate is Bishop to a four which will
result in Bishop to d1 and now black no
longer has any moves there is no way to
prevent Bishop to d1 and this is
basically the solution to your puzzle
because after you try something let's
say Knight to e2 you try to eliminate
the g3 point so maybe the black King can
escape now Bishop to d1
you just spin the night and next move
you're gonna capture it there's nothing
for black to do here after c4 let's say
something you just capture it and after
this it's just checkmate
so it's a incredible even to imagine
that that this position ends in white
checkmating black but it's just one of
those puzzles that's that's truly
incredible again by the by the Dutch in
game composer Hayes from Brooklyn so do
tell your friends at the bar in the
library about him as he sees it seems
like really also awesome dude composing
this masterpiece like I said there in
the description below I will put a link
to the article and chess based comm
there are a whole lot of stories about
this puzzle so you definitely want to
check it out really really just
impressive stuff but yeah that's that's
the puzzle I do hope you enjoyed it and
I don't know if you enjoyed it maybe
maybe we can show some some other
incredible puzzles but you know though
don't expect any of them to be this
incredible this is just a masterpiece
and as they say in the story you know
the type to a crack at it then he went
for a walk and then during his walk he
was able to solve it without actually
looking at the board then he came back
and he presented the puzzle the solution
to the puzzle which which you know
pretty much no one no one is able to
solve no Grand Master's solved that
there at this at this tournament and
even today's engines as you can see
struggle with it unless unless they have
access to the cloud analysis where the
position was already solved but yeah
really impressive stuff I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank John
Lynch habla Roger
pehle Abdul Latif Rainer temple music
and Marvin Sparrow for contribution to
my channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it
usually you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Morphy
saga checking up near wonderful
suggestions and of course whatever else
happens in the chess world so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day